[Music]
you think you know what is real
and what isn't
[Music]
what is light
what is dark
now
forget all you know
come with me
[Music]
we're looking for the sorcerer willow
i was told that once long ago you
defeated the forces of evil you remind
me of your mother
my dear friend
i thought i could prevent all this
i was wrong
my brother was abducted the world needs
you again it needs your magic follow me
we must go
beyond the edge of our world
into the unknown
i need your help just like old times
running horses
happy to see it
our true enemy is still out there
rallying the forces of evil
and the only thing standing in his path
is us
i'm going to enjoy this if you think
you're going to think it's amazing
very much take him to my tent make sure
he's tied up i don't know see that kind
of sounds like on the same page
when i was a kid i used to play it being
a sorcerer
visiting strange worlds fighting
monsters
never thought i'd actually really do it
what the hell is that
trolls i'm so miffed
same as last time
with my friends
[Music]
[Music]
you